all right so today we have Austin Allred
he is the CEO of lambda school which was
in the summer 2017 batch and lambda
school is ACS education that is free
until you get a job so Austin what I
wanted to ask you about you mentioned
this on a few podcasts that I've
listened to you on and basically there's
this core idea in lambda school that you
have to be kind of confident enough to
even apply and this is a great
opportunity for many people but what I'm
curious about is how do you encourage
people to do something that's probably
good for them that they might just be
scared to do or they make excuses about
yeah I mean I think that's that's the
actually the problem we grapple with the
most and you know I think Patrick
Collison said something along the lines
of you know if you think about it the
highest leverage activity any human can
have is inspiring other humans to do
what they're capable of and in many ways
I see lambda school as like the the
realization of that so we've had a lot
of students in the past you would
graduate and then whenever you felt
ready you would start applying for jobs
and we have students that would just
wait and wait and wait and we'd be like
what you know why are they not working
hard what's going on and you talk to
them and you realize it's massive
impostor syndrome they're just not
they're not confident or comfortable
with the idea that they're now a
software engineer and so they're just
kind of procrastinating that so we now
we have some mechanisms that get you to
you know start applying earlier but yeah
like the minute they start applying they
get interviews they get hired they get a
six-figure job and it's like what what
were we waiting for right you're totally
capable and what about what about the
people before lamb to school a few of
the questions that came from Twitter
were basically like isn't this just an
opportunity for rich people you know
like being able to leave your job and
commit full-time to a seven-month
program yeah my first answer to that
would be we have part-time programs as
well so you can do it evenings and
weekends we have experiments running
where we pay people living stipends that
will be expanding greatly we'll be
announcing something in the near future
along those lines in concert with a few
other tech leaders here in the valley
but but yeah I mean the number one
problem we have to solve on the
admission side is getting the people who
are qualified to actually apply yeah
it's it's kind of a you wouldn't think
of it as being a problem
it's a YC problem too um yeah but no it
totally is yeah some of the best
companies there's like I just don't know
if I can get into YC and that's that's a
difficulty of having a good reputation
where a lot of people want to go there
you just they're people who assume that
they won't get in which is not the case
right I mean so your acceptance rate
maybe it's changed but I heard you say
it's 25% of the people who make it
through that first initial test the
people that make it through the
pre-course work it might even be higher
now I mean though a free course work is
more difficult but the vast majority of
our selection mechanism is the
pre-course work of how well you do on it
if you put in the time sometimes I
wonder if we could just make the
pre-course work really long and have
that beat it no no interview no nothing
just just the work yeah I mean because
that's obviously like your business
hinges on you assessing that risk right
correct and so if you could make it
sufficiently difficult yeah it would
work yeah in theory I mean you run the
risk of false negatives
yeah or false positives I guess but but
yeah that all that we need to find out
is are you of average you know mental
intelligence and will you work really
hard yeah and I think YC is similar
right like I've when I got into YC I
felt super intimidated there were and
there are brilliant people all over in
the room yeah but just because you went
you have a PhD in computer science from
MIT and you got a 1600 on the SATs as a
freshman doesn't necessarily mean you
have a successful company it's not
directly correlated I think in the in
the past it's possible that YC was
fooled more often by fancy degrees and
PhDs and stuff like that possibly yeah
not the case anymore
I mean I had in my wife Ste group there
were a couple they're like a 15 and a 16
year old group yeah
yeah that was a that was a fringe case
yeah so I I'm curious about like there's
this core insight with lambda school
which centers around what what if we
didn't have to charge ten thousand
dollars before at this you know deaf
school how did you reach that point so I
was living in rural Utah before I moved
to San Francisco and when you moved to
San Francisco from a small town and you
see just the discrepancy in opportunity
I guess so it was easy to look around
rural Utah and be like look that guy is
just as capable and intelligent as that
guy in San Francisco yeah but in Utah
that guy's making 30k in San Francisco
that guy's making 150 and he's leaving a
team so you know how does that work out
is it just what jobs are available and I
mean if you talk to people you realize
it's it's more about opportunity than
anything so to tell a guy that's making
30k hey just drop you know 10k on an
education and there's a 7% interest rate
on the other side and hopefully it works
out that's that's actually a really big
ask so I have to put it in terms for VCS
sometimes and say like imagine spending
half of your annual income on an
education on a bet right you have most
VCS or very well-off and you have that
kind of risk that you can take so you
have to kind of put it into that similar
psychological context that people just
can't afford that risk so why are people
in these situations signing up for
University of Phoenix type programs but
not the dev schools because it's a
similar choice right so I think the
first reason is honestly because the
University of Phoenix is more aggressive
in their marketing tactics they I mean
they have the they don't really care
whether you succeed to some degree if
they can you know they're backed by the
loans are backed by Uncle Sam and
whether or not you're successful they
get paid yeah so the incentives are
fundamentally misaligned and if the
University of Phoenix can get you to
sign a piece of paper they get 80 grand
okay
and that's
but the reason people are the reason
people opt for universities generally
speaking versus you know code schools is
they've you know my entire life growing
up nobody ever said there's a path to
success that's not college yeah and I'm
not a college graduate
my older brother isn't a college
graduate a lot of very successful people
I know are not graduates but yeah
everybody growing up just said go to
college doesn't matter what it costs
just get a degree doesn't matter what
you study and you'll be successful and I
think my generation is now realizing
like that's fundamentally untrue it
isn't only not good advice it's probably
bad advice net net and the newer
generation has the benefit of seeing
people with hundreds of thousands of
dollars in student loans and working at
Starbucks
yeah and clearly something was off in
the advice that we were given well yeah
yeah I mean I went to NYU I graduated
with like 50 yeah that's pretty good
going to NYU okay yeah I got a bunch of
scholarship and it worked out alright
yeah yeah still a lot of debt to be
clear yeah dude I was an English major
so I guess all the jobs I've gotten have
been through skills I've learned outside
of NYU obviously I can write fairly well
for sure but the real upside was being
in a huge city where I could start
working early and I think that was a
real competitive advantage and I'm
curious about lambda school in this way
because at NYU you know once I started I
never went home again you know every
summer I was working and then I was
working during the year and then I was
like realizing that I could cram all my
classes on one or two days and work
full-time mm-hmm and so I had easily a
four year advantage on all my friends
who went to you know like Colgate or
something I'm so the middle of nowhere
right so how do you take advantage of
that at lambda school like getting
people in early getting them a network
yeah so so there are a couple things one
is you know lambda school is nine months
full-time versus a 40 degree which is
obviously four years
so our the average land
we'll grad if you were if you had two
students one started a university at the
same time as another student started
lambda school by the time the students
graduating from University the landing
school student has three years of
experience and has paid land to school
off and is a quarter-million dollars
ahead at least of the University grad so
you know net net it's it's pretty
obvious but the the network is pretty
key yeah so most of our students are
coming in with no network a lot of
students from either inner cities or
rural areas and we basically have to
help them build that and then build a
network around them so we have a
full-time team that is just bringing in
companies to hire students part of the
school itself is actually okay here's
how you network here's how you find
other people with similar backgrounds
hired in engineering roles on LinkedIn
now we're gonna go contact them we're
that's actually built into the
curriculum oh I didn't realize that sir
yeah can you actually break those down
I'm very curious about how you you know
tactically explain networking skills cuz
I know you wrote a growth book on for
land of school right so you're kind of
like into breaking these things down
yeah so yeah say I'm a graduate or I'm
inland school at what point do you start
teaching me I guess you could call it
soft skills so now you meet your career
coach at week three okay so it's very
integrated into like it it is lambda
school right it's not a separate
external thing and we have careers
lessons every week for the for the
entire school so for example the you
know we train students to do
informational interviews which is find
someone with a similar educational
background to you so use linkedin's
advanced search and search for schools
that are XYZ in locations that are this
and with careers that are this now you
have a huge list of people who are just
like you reach out to them and ask if
you can grab coffee just or jump on a
phone call and say hey I want to break
into this field what do I do to break
into this field and probably our best
job offers actually come through that
your best job offers always come
through networking and meeting people
we're really close to the point at which
we just say you know if you have to use
an application to like click and apply
button somewhere just throw it in the
garbage don't don't do that anymore or
at a minimum we'll have somebody else do
that for you
so now to help with that we are hiring
right now 37 interview sorcerer's so
those are folks that are just going out
they'll take your specific information
and they'll go out and help find
companies as well and bring the
companies to you so we have an entire
team that's dedicated to that Wow
the future we're going to look a lot
like a talent agency basically for
software engineers and designers and
whatever else right right right
so in terms of the other there are a
couple questions around well so John
Palmer asks can or what other pieces of
the university experience can be
unbundled and the thing that I'm in
particular curious about is the way you
treat education in the sense of language
school it's like hey this is job
training right like this is the goal of
making money it's not about you know
being altruistic and necessarily making
artists or whatever you want to call it
right
do you see a traditional value in a
traditional liberal arts education and
like those elements let's cool for sure
so I I see value absolutely in the
liberal arts right I do disagree that a
the only way you can learn the liberal
arts is within the walls of a university
so you know in my mind a lot of the
people that that we're talking to you
know if you're 35 and you've never had a
very high-paying career yeah the
prospect of let's take out $50,000 of
loans to study Shakespeare is not a bad
thing per se but probably not the right
thing at the right time yeah so we are
yeah we're entirely vocational we're a
trade school basically and we want to
help you make as much money as you can
and then when you're making a lot of
money it's a
a lot easier to make decisions around
what you'll learn in the liberal arts in
fact that may be an add-on we add to the
school later but not it's just not the
focus right now there are a lot of
people that do a really good job at that
and we're okay to leave that to them for
Nia yeah because I think that's it's one
of those things similarly to signing a
student loan when you're 18 like you
don't really know the terms of the day I
mean you get leg you can read it on
paper but you don't really understand
the dynamic you're about to enter
mhm whereas when you're say yeah you're
35 thinking about switching careers here
you're much more practically minded yeah
or you might just be interested in idle
Jing I think we've romanticized it a
little bit right like I went to the
liberal arts portion of the liberal arts
degree before I got into the
specialization and like it was valuable
but it's I've learned way more by
reading books and meeting people and
other stuff than I did in the university
so i get the value but i don't buy the
argument that like that's the only time
and only place that you can become
well-rounded yeah that doesn't make
sense to me yeah i mean do you see there
are valid there are elements of value in
unbundling other aspects and like really
building that into lambda school for
sure yeah yeah okay
so there's another question here from
Steve clay bore Kleber Noble who asks as
competitors begin to copy your model
which is we should talk about it's an
income sharing agreement what what front
do you believe you'll be competing on
all of them so so the way I describe
lambda school is it's you know people
know lambda school because of the
business model but the business model is
something that's upfront that's not what
makes lambda school works yeah right you
can you can you can charge whatever you
want or however you want the key is
making that successful so our product
our educational experience is I think
among the best in the world and it has
to be the way we've built it in order to
make a free up front and online
education work I mean when we started
our dropout rate is what was killing us
now we're graduating you know more
85% of students that start day one and a
lot of the drop out is because of
reasons outside of our control its
financial or life circumstance or
whatever else yeah so we have we have a
product that people love they come out
on the other side is great software
engineers and we have a hiring Network
ready to hire them that's all really
difficult then the admissions side of
knowing who and how and what to accept
like that's not it's not something you
can buy right you just have to like
figure that out over time and eventually
it'll be very data driven very you know
we'll be able to tell on before a
student begins Lam to school what
they're likely to be hired at and what
their likely outcome will be yeah
similar to you know a lending company
yeah but there's no credit score for
people right you can't say like what is
this person's potential there's no
there's no inputs that you can take
right now that can determine that so
nobody knows how to underwrite student
risk nobody knows how to train students
online nobody knows how to place
students nationally and scale and
figuring all that stuff out is the hard
part
right plugging throwing an ISA on the
front end is the easy part
yeah okay so you're just hoping I like
your mut you're much further ahead than
people realize way further yeah yeah and
I'm sure there will be competitors sure
the the thing that scares me is in
somebody adopting our business model
that probably has happened that I
haven't heard about will happen a
million more times what what will make
us win is the student experience and how
fast we can move in making that better
over time
yeah and that includes the outcomes the
students have so all of my time and
effort energy is focused on that and
that's really freaking hard okay it's
hard yeah so yeah is it so you were
profitable before you did YC right
correct
okay all right yeah maybe not usually
profitable but profitable we were
profitable by any definition yeah there
yeah okay cool so was there an element
of fear around being copied that that
led you in the path of
money No
so we actually sat down with a YC
partner and we said okay we don't need
to raise money right now but if we do
we'll suffer
X % so we modeled it out we actually
created a financial model okay and said
here's the dilution that will suffer and
with that money that will raise we'll be
able to grow like this
yeah and therefore you know and it came
out to something like lambda school will
be 10 times bigger than it otherwise
would be and it will suffer call it 15%
dilution so that's an easy trade-off if
you actually model it out and that's the
reason we have continued to raise I mean
before we started Lam to school I was
like I'm never raising VC again right
well we should tell that's right oh that
was a cool story yeah so and now we've
Ray it's a year and a half later and
we've raised 48 million and it's not
going to be the last we've raised right
but if you look at the growth rate of
the school and the revenue if you look
at any number all of those raises were a
wise decision in retrospect and there's
a reason VC exists right when you have a
company that can grow at extreme scale
and capture a market and create way more
value that's why you raise VC and the
realization for us was realizing that
land school could be a successful
bootstrapped company but if we raised
and use a little bit of fuel we could
just be much bigger and much more
impactful yeah well I don't actually
don't think it's dissimilar from student
loans like there's a dynamic where it
works really well for you sure and there
are other dynamics where if you don't
know the terms of the deal beforehand
there are different incentives and it
doesn't work out well for you right
right so this is kind of you got burned
before with your first company yes yeah
so this I mean if I remember correctly
right you were about to raise an A and
then it just fell through we had we had
Docs done for an a which is not normally
when things fall through it was a very
abnormal story so it was I mean
December 23rd we're waiting for a wire
any day and then the gentleman who was
leading our series egg called me and
said actually we're not
we actually had his secretary call me
and say actually we're not doing the
deal and I said can you tell us why I'm
like wow we're just not confident in the
company after you know a month of due
diligence and going through all the
paperwork and I mean our law firm was
like we have we've done thousands of
these deals we've never seen this happen
and we were like out of money so that
was I thought like I didn't want people
to go through the holidays planning on
coming to work in January and then the
company not being there right so I
called the whole team on December 23rd
and said I think it's over guys I don't
I don't know what other options we have
and we had other people who would have
funded us but it's really difficult to
like hey you know how we went down in a
month and a half with that come you know
with that VC well they pulled out so you
should fund us that's not it's very
momentum driven so that's why I was very
anti VC now I think there are companies
that should raise we see they're
companies that shouldn't be see it's
just dependent on the circumstances and
the details and what you're looking for
so yeah yeah but then you left and you
went to go work for another startup
right after after writing the book so
the so I was broke um where I was
working remotely in the middle of
nowhere in Utah during this time yeah so
we go back home it's not like they're
tech jobs I mean the closest tech job
was probably two hours away an hour and
a half away out of money well I use all
my savings to make employees and
contractors whole because we were
burning it down to the the wire with the
company funds and then my daughter who
was born ended up in the hospital for a
month
so we were just like actually she was
only in there for a week but it felt
like a month and now the bills might may
as well have been for a month so we're
out of money trying to figure out how to
recover and I had written a couple of
blog posts about growth as we were
working on the company that had taken
off and so I said okay we're going to
turn those
blog posts into a book and I emailed
everybody who would subscribe to my blog
and said all right we're launching this
Kickstarter and I'm gonna finish up this
book and the Kickstarter did something
like $120,000 in sales
I mean that's what I'm good at right I
can how many people were on the list a
couple thousand that's really good
third yeah that's if there's one thing
I'm good at in life it's growing
something quickly building hype for
something quickly yeah that's kind of my
superpower in some degree so use that in
its fullest for the first time and then
a few companies saw the book and said
hey come work for us
one of which was lend up which is a YC
company yep so this is it's still
interesting because it's fairly risky
you know oh you're gonna like you lived
in the bay before you know like you
lived in your car yeah right and then
you move back to Utah you could conceive
of getting a tech job right rather than
writing your book at that time for sure
why didn't you do that so I did both
right it was just it was whatever I can
do to get money right now and a book was
honestly faster than a job hunt
well maybe that's not true because I
could have yeah it's actually not true I
don't know that offers like within days
yeah so I imagine the scenario is like
hey here's something like I've been
really interested in this like idea in
question lately of like at what point
did you kind of find your voice and and
you know people talk about that in the
context of art but I think it's the same
for entrepreneurs and that kind of
confidence like oh I'm just gonna do my
thing and I could yeah so it's it's
funny I had as everything was winding
down I went one to one of our past
investors and I was like what you know
what am I gonna do and I was paying
myself I'd started out paying myself
40,000 and I'd recently given myself a
raise to 60,000 and I went to that
investor
and I was like what you know how can I
pull this out I don't know what I'm
gonna do next and he said well you know
you don't have any marketable skills
you're you're never gonna make more than
$60,000 a year so maybe you should go
find an internship somewhere I was like
okay it's like that's where you're like
mindset is right maybe I can make
$60,000 a year yeah so I actually made
sure that the first job offer I got was
double that just just out of spite but
it took me a while to build up the
confidence to like you know people were
telling me that well when you're the CEO
of a company your only job is to make
that company successful and if that
company fails by definition you're not a
good CEO right you could debate whether
or not that's true but that's yeah
realistically one or zero successful
right
and so that calls into question well
what do you actually do what are you
good at do you have a skill set yeah and
I never worked I'd worked in like
marketing before but never in growth
growth and so I was like I don't I don't
know if there's anything I can do yeah
and I didn't believe that people would
trust that I had like a skill set that
was valuable because I had investors
telling me you don't and clearly they
know more than I do right so it was a
psychological psychologically difficult
time and I thought you know the only way
I can show people what I can do is by
publishing this book right it's funny to
think about that I've never thought
about that but in retrospect starting a
company is by definition saying I think
what I can do is worth more than people
will pay me for yeah right I think that
I can do something whether it's because
you can't measure
I think Paul Graham has an essay about
this something about measurement and
leverage and how companies can can't do
any of those things very well so if you
want to get to a place where you can
make a lot of money get to a place where
you can measure it get to a place where
you have leverage
and so you look at pro athletes like
yeah anybody can measure the number of
dollars that Michael Jordan brings in so
it makes sense to pay him a hundred
million dollars a year right whereas
even if you're the best software
engineer in the world at a small company
they're not gonna pay you 100 million
dollars a year yeah Google might oh well
has spent a hundred million dollars to
retain sundar and stuff like that but
but yeah it's it's I it's mispriced
human capital is kind of fundamental to
it yeah but it's also a core to your
business but that like that's that yeah
I think that's the key that is the
insight is saying you know there if you
look at any asset class in the United
States it's being traded on Bloomberg
terminals instantly all over the world
right so you can trade you know a
hundred thousand pounds of porkbelly's
without anything moving and it's priced
instantly and there are a million people
trying to figure out what the accurate
price is for those pork bellies but for
some reason humans don't have that right
it's you get a job or you don't and I'm
there specifically there have been women
who applied to lambda school we get to
the negotiation stage and they say you
know I have always been paid X and we
have to say you're worth more than to X
so we're going to pay you what we
actually think market is and turns out
they just always been underpaid and they
didn't know to ask for more and I think
that happens all the time all the time
well you going because the thing is when
you start out you're just applying for
jobs right and you take what you can get
and then like you mentioned before many
of these you know quote great jobs are
never advertised right and so you you
anchor in this weird way that until you
know people who make 400 grand a year
you're just like well the job says 75
grand a year right and and and that's
awesome too like you know if you're
making thirty five 75 s killin it
right Frank but then you're just like oh
there's probably like some ceiling at
like 100 something and you're like
dancers actually know right it just
keeps going but companies are
incentivized to not publish that as well
right
right no it's yeah it's a and that's a
funny thing when you get to Silicon
Valley and you see like there is a
desperation around top talent and there
are people commanding you know million
dollar salaries and the companies will
happily pay it obviously that's not an
entry-level salary but and there are
people in the Midwest who are capable of
being paid six figures in the Midwest
that are making 20 in the Midwest
yeah and that's crazy to me like that's
the problem we're really out to solve
why why is there no mechanism to help
people realize their full potential both
an economic standpoint and a non
economic standpoint and why is there not
like there's nowhere near an efficient
marketplace for capital no nowhere close
and that's crazy because if you look at
GDP and spending and like where we can
make the most improvement as far as
efficiency goes human capital is the
most optimized asset class we've ever
had yeah and that's insane
well despecialized in factories for the
most part right right so aside from to
the tech jobs that you offer right now
what other opportunities you see is like
really great for arbitrage in that way
so right now we're hiring an economist
to help us make sense of all that hmm
but some of it you don't have to be an
economist to see you know you can talk
or download data from the US Department
of Labor and see like how many people
are applying for the jobs and how many
jobs are out there and there are some
that have drastic like three-to-one
shortages that pay really well and there
just aren't enough people so nursing is
one of them every nursing school is at
capacity because they have some so
there's something called the 90/10 rule
which says that only 90 percent of your
money as a school can come from federal
funds mm the other 10% has to come
through people paying tuition or private
sources somehow and that is actually the
thing that dry
the education system in the United
States that 10% finding that 10% so
every school is just desperately trying
to find that 10% and however big that
10% is they can blow the rest out with
federal funds all day so nursing schools
for example there's a huge shortage of
nurses boomers are getting old
Millennials aren't going into medicine
but nursing schools are capped because
they can't find that 10% and so it's
like that drives massive labor shortages
across the entire economy mm-hmm and
that since that's crazy right that's
just that's just a market inefficiency
so you know we're not working on it
right right now but don't be surprised
if you hear by the end of this year an
announcement that lambda nursing is
going live and we're launching a nursing
school or you know so we look at it
backwards from a labor market
perspective yeah and we're starting out
with where are the shortages in labor
markets and let's fill those gaps and
turns out some of those gaps are 5
million people at a time and that's a
huge inefficiency and if we can be a
toll road that takes a very small toll
to get you there
yeah it's an enormous company so yeah I
think so too yeah so ok I'm curious
about then how you end up modeling that
risk if the program I imagine the
nursing program might be a little bit
longer than nine months huh you're gonna
have to give people I imagine like
you're talking about testing out these
living stipends stuff like that how do
you start modeling that risk um in the
beginning you make good guesses and you
put it on a spreadsheet and you give
yourself a margin of error Newsome yeah
yeah I mean it looks like any other
FinTech industry where you start out
saying all right we're gonna make some
loans we don't really know how it's
gonna work out we're gonna learn from
that and over time we'll have a really
predictive model we're getting better on
the just income share agreement for
education side for software engineering
right we're not all the way there but we
we had to some degree know what can
predict what the returns will be given
the Mac
economic environment staying the same
okay
so you kind of just have to like create
terms that make sense and figure it out
as you go and then you know when we talk
about a moat over time you can better
predict what repayment will be you can
better predict - how much money you're
going to make you can write a tighter
model if you can write a tighter model
you can bring down the cost of capital
you can bring down your cost or you can
increase the services that students get
there's just a fundamental advantage to
having done that before and now we've
got a couple years head start on
everybody else and we can pretty act I
mean not with a hundred percent accuracy
but we have a pretty good sense of how
successful a student will be by the time
they're starting or a couple months now
and you know we have we're hiring teams
that are going to focus on just that how
can we shorten that feedback loop so
that we can determine very quickly how
successful people will be can you kind
of quantify someone's work ethic or grit
no but they all along the way will spit
off data that you can use to try to
approach that so the numbers are an
output not your input but I mean
similarly to a startup right like you
can't quantify the grit of founders but
you can look at what they're doing and
the results of that you could
retroactively Li say yeah that looks
gritty and if you get enough data points
machine learning is actually like that's
one of the places where AI makes the
most sense is saying you know let's take
all of this data and let's figure out a
model that maybe humans couldn't put
together but computers can figure it out
and pretty soon you can underwrite the
likelihood that a person will be a
successful software engineer before
they've paid a dollar yeah and then that
changes everything
so what someone asks us questions I want
to I want to credit them somewhere oh no
I know who it was yeah David copied wind
basically yes
imagine a market dynamic where it's
mostly white dudes getting hired for
software engineering jobs is it possible
that your model could learn and
wrong way and say only select white
dudes for lambda school so it could if
that's what we're actually happening hmm
[Music]
that's not what's actually happening the
reality is if we can make someone to be
make someone a strong software engineer
they're getting hired anywhere but but I
mean there there are ethical concerns
that we have to be aware of right I mean
I used to work in lending you have to be
very cognizant of that in lending
because for example if you use zip code
and you say look the people from this
zip code tend not to repay zip code is
very directly correlated with
demographics and their ethical concerns
you have to be wise about what we're
seeing right now is actually the reverse
to some degree so obviously not you know
it's not causation by any stretch of the
imagination but we can tap into markets
of completely untapped talent because
we're not charging anything folks who
are brilliant just haven't had
opportunity before and so you
we actually over index to those types of
communities so we're I think is a school
we're less than half white hmm which is
not the traditional makeup of a code
school by any stretch of the imagination
but that's not because we're like
intentionally guess cueing admissions
that way it's just because that's where
a lot of untapped talent is and we try
to find and train that untapped talent
and companies are happy to have it in
fact it's a huge need for companies we
don't sell ourselves is diversity
solution but it happens that our
students who aren't great engineers are
generally speaking more diverse than
Stanford would be yeah that makes sense
so a great question yeah no it's really
interesting I was yeah yeah so you guys
now are remote right so like all the
coursework happens livestream do you see
a version where you become centralized
you buy I mean like I my buddy just he
worked at a college in Vermont that just
went under right I
imagine you can buy colleges at this
point like yeah yeah yeah do you see a
world where you're like I mean maybe
probably with a nursing program you'll
have to you would have to Baia yeah I
mean it changes it changes the cost
structure so the less we can be in
person the better yeah we have some
experiments that we're running where we
are actually housing people in group
housing together so they live and work
in the same environment they're still
taught on lines because it's we don't
have to have the density of instructors
in one place at one time we can just get
students together yeah I mean I've
looked at hey can we just buy a summer
camp and yeah and run camp lambda and
have like I'll be awesome yeah we just
have to like decentralized housing is
much cheaper than centralized
yeah so students would have to be
willing to build that into the cost so I
what I like to say is you know you look
at Amazon Amazon in the beginning was
saying no we're entirely online we're
going to be focused there but once
that's nailed then you start to play
with other stuff will probably be the
same way but the core of Landon school
for the foreseeable future is online
whether students are in the same place
or not we actually have a monthly meetup
in every major city in the u.s. our
students all get together in person and
that's working pretty well so there may
be more of that especially as we have
more density but but the educational
experience will probably always be
online yeah I mean that this is what
I've heard from you know like the guys
at zapier who were just saying you
basically have to be intentional and
like build that it remotecall very
intentional because if you don't you
could easily see a version where oh you
weren't in class today then you don't
hear the thing you didn't hear the tip
right yeah okay and I think you have to
do that as a company as a school like it
it's not something that happens on
accident yeah and in the beginning you
know we started out by figuring out okay
here all these people who could be
watching Netflix right now so it
actually goes back to our instructional
design where I mean now if I think back
to my college classes maybe 50% of
people were
paying attention if I'm being optimistic
at least I mean this was you know call
it 2010 at least 50% of the class was on
Facebook I think you have you seen those
photos from back in the day when
Facebook just started so yeah I'm sure I
don't think it's photoshopped but I
imagine there's a real one out there
somewhere where it's like from the back
of the class and the professors talking
like it's 70% of the screens or Facebook
oh yeah yeah yeah so for better or worse
I actually think it's a secret advantage
is that we can't rely on the crutch of
just like looking at somebody and seeing
what they're doing so we have to use
data and software and instructional
design to make sure everybody's working
on the right thing at the right time so
I mean yeah it's it's a different world
that you have to build for and you have
to build it for it from first principles
it's like you can't just tack down that
on at the end oh by the way we're online
that doesn't matter
does not work well most MOOCs here yeah
disasters credit ten percent or
something yeah the good ones yeah yeah
it's crazy so Dave Dawson asked several
good questions
he says you appear to be on the
successful path now we'll just take that
for granted
sure was there a point early on and
landed school when you wanted to stop
there was never a point I wanted to stop
I mean I I would if you paid me minimum
wage to do this forever I would do this
forever for minimum wage
maybe I'm just to say this for
masochists or something yeah yeah I
might have to move back to Utah yeah but
there are definitely times when it was
just like this is not going to work and
we're screwed and I mean in the
beginning it was like all those other
schools were right like when we started
everybody said hey you can't teach
people effectively online B you can't
teach people effectively without skin in
the game they have to put something up
yeah you know see people aren't going to
get jobs if you don't if they don't have
a network like you can't accept the
categories of people that you're
accepting and have them be successful
software engine
which like looking back like a
ridiculous thing to say yeah but
everybody believed that like the the
entire code bootcamp industry believed
that online was not very effective
because they're all like we have an
in-person class and like yeah let's like
throw it online and oh it didn't work
well clearly that's fundamentally broken
yeah everybody who had ever tried a free
upfront thing didn't use any sort of
filtering other than a paper resume and
so and people would show up on day one
and they wouldn't show up on day two and
they would say oh that's clearly isn't
working and so yeah there are a whole
lot of times when we said this like
maybe they were right that was the real
reaction like maybe we were wrong this
whole time and you know we're out here
saying hey you guys are all old school
you're all doing it the wrong way we're
gonna do it over here well maybe maybe
there's a reason that hundreds of years
of education have been have worked this
way yeah but really I think what what
happens is like we don't have another
option right we have to figure it out or
we die yeah and that's a very powerful
motivator yeah not getting a real job
yeah yeah have you ever completed a
online course before that is not right
okay
and in fact we were talking about the
book the book was available as an online
download yeah and one of the things that
made me want to build in this model and
I sold the book for a hundred bucks
right it was it was not cheap no fifty
percent of the people that bought the
book ever downloaded it even so there's
you know between looking at that and
looking at MOOCs it was like has anybody
ever figured out how to make education
actually successful yeah or are we all
just opening the top of the funnel so
wide that some people are gonna fall out
the bottom and like and that's become my
thesis is that there's some percentage
of society who are autodidact and they
just have a ridiculous advantage over
everybody else and so part of land of
school is how can we help the other 98%
learn
how to be autodidactic how to see a
proxy a problem approach it figure that
figure out a solution and I don't so we
approached instructional design with no
assumptions and I think every school
ever has looked at everything and said
ok well here the successful students so
our job is just to weed everybody else
out yeah
when really like why are those why are
the other students unsuccessful is that
because they suck or is that because you
suck yeah and we found that it's really
just because you suck most of the time
and it's really easy for schools to just
look the other way huh
I have been wondering I'm doing a
duolingo right now uh-huh and I've been
curious about I mean it's cool but it's
very open like you can just choose where
you want to go if they like motivate you
a little bit by keeping a streak up but
I'm actually a little surprised that
people if people finish it because I'm
doing it everyday but I think if you
guess what their completion numbers were
you'd be right yeah and I think about
you know when I went to college and I
had a class and I showed up and it was a
Shakespeare class I think about the work
that I put in in that class and then the
work that I put in outside of that class
there's no way in hell I put in as much
work studying Shakespeare on my own as I
would in the four walls of a university
hmm but I don't think that's because
there was a physical campus with a
professor wearing a tweed jacket
necessarily that's just because there
there was social pressure there's
instructional design there were external
mechanisms that force you to put in the
work yeah so we had to like that's what
we built into lambda school but you also
have to make it fun total you have to
motivate in that way you know it's why I
learned to program it's why I learned to
video edit it's why I learned everything
on the side because you had a clear goal
like hey I want to build this thing and
it's enjoyable to build the thing you
want to build well so you look at as an
example computer science programs right
they have ridiculous dropout and they're
proud of that
but in my opinion it's because they
start like writing Java or they start
writing C and you're you have to go
semesters before you get to a point
where you can write any code that you
can see or touch or actually play with
and so like yes you're getting the
fundamentals but lambda school works the
other way so you have a site that you
can play with the first day and it's not
you know you don't understand the
fundamentals of programming it's crab
dhtml and scrappy CSS yeah but you can
see it you can touch it you can play
with it and I think there are a lot of
people if not the majority of people
that learn that way
yeah and they're the people who aren't
going to become researchers and that's
okay
and just because you start at that point
doesn't mean you can't drill down until
you're doing the fundamentals like you
do need to know how to write C to be a
good engineer you do need to know how
memory management works but maybe let's
not start with memory management as like
an entry-level point to software
engineering ya know I did a a year of CS
and even high school and it was just
like what are we doing this for right
what is the point
and there are a few people that are
interested by that enough that they can
carry on but that's not enough people to
build the world of software that we need
know so yeah yeah so Dave asks another
question that I want to cover and that
is what keeps you up at night now so we
we agreed as a team to no longer share
the number of students that we have
enrolled but it is not a small number
and it is growing at an insane pace yeah
it will will soon be measuring land
school scale by percentage of the
overall number of students learning to
program every year to give you some
context and being able to support that
kind of scale effectively is what keeps
me up at night mostly specifically
hiring mostly hiring executives right
now who can build out hundred hundred
fifty person teams beneath
those people are difficult to find and
it's a very important decision and we
need like five of them yesterday and
then you know on the individual
contributor side
we're probably we need to hire like a
hundred people very quickly hmm
and that is hard but that would be
remote right those jobs it mostly would
be remote correct yeah so if you're
looking for a job yeah please
I think we're hiring for like 50
positions right now lambda school comm
slash careers yeah please please all
right so I want to talk about the
couples like two other topics so one
actually really like this one
day-o called callie ohh-ho yes I've made
remarks I do not agree with that's a
quote from your Twitter bio yeah you're
a prolific on Twitter if people don't
follow you
what is that one remark you wish you
didn't have to disagree with one remark
that I so I think what he's trying to
get you to say is what is something that
you may have had to like say or go back
on and perhaps like politically correct
or like environmentally there are a lot
of layers to that question that's a
tricky one so or maybe even a core
belief where you're just like oh maybe
I'm just wrong here so the one that I go
back and forth on the most is as a
company being remote versus in person
and the trade-offs of that so we bring
people together a lot and I see the
advantages of that and a lot of our
executive team will probably end up
being in person and so it's I would say
that I wish that remote work were at
this incredible place where there's no
trade-off and I think that's something
that everybody wants to believe and some
people do believe but until you're kind
of in the CEO or executive role trying
to bring a company together you don't
see some of the trade-offs the
so I I mean I would love to be able to
move anywhere and not pay what I pay for
rent and by extension not pay everybody
else but I have to pay them so that they
can pay rent yeah but I still think and
you know a lot of our students come in
wanting to be remote a I don't think
remote work is built into enough
companies yet where I would be
comfortable telling somebody that I love
that they should start their career as a
remote junior software engineer B I
think we're still figuring out what the
right dynamic is of in person versus
remote like as as a tech industry what
the trade-offs are and what the ideal
way to do that is my first company was
entirely remote and that's really hard
we're trying to come together and create
something but nobody's in the same spot
they're just trade-offs that said all of
our instructors are remote all of our
career coaches are remote and all of our
students are remote and because we've
built around that we've built into that
it doesn't matter but I think the two
things that are most like my most
controversial beliefs maybe or most like
seemingly like don't seem to jive with
each other is that I think the best
high-growth companies are still going to
be built in Silicon Valley for right now
or at least they'll having an executive
team in Silicon Valley but also I
believe the best schools are remote and
I don't think that's a contradiction
though it certainly feels like one
mm-hmm
yeah yeah that's good think about ya
know I was listening to Michael Seibel
talk yesterday and he said he's had his
mind changed about remote
company's given the success of you know
get labs up here type companies right
but the way he puts it now is that it
has to be one of your like core things
one of your like core innovations and if
you're thinking like maybe we have the
energy or the insight to innovate on a
couple maybe three categories like are
you willing for remote work to be one of
them yeah I think that's exactly right
you can only solve so many problems as a
company and I mean I I've talked to the
CEOs of both zapier and get lab in the
past couple weeks and they think about
that all the time
yeah and the nice thing is the talent
advantages that you have when you do
that are enormous you know one zapier is
like yeah we are like this guy in Ohio
and this guy in Nebraska it's like man
you know I'm hiring but at the same time
that the trade-offs are that if you're
if you you know you have an office in
the financial district and you're hiring
five executives there are a hundred
companies that have been high-growth
that you know the funny thing is a lot
of the people who they join a
high-growth company they know how to
grow it they figured it out now they're
successful and they have less incentive
to move than other people do yeah so
like I think the pool of high-growth
executive talent with 15 years of
experience growing high-growth companies
is still largely concentrated in San
Francisco like if you need or call it
Silicon Valley whatever if you if you
need 50 people to do that it's really
difficult to find 50 people in Ohio to
do that if it's still difficult to find
50 people anywhere but yeah if you've
built that in like get lab and zapier
have you know in other companies like
envision or whatever else they've chosen
that is their path and they have to
spend a whole lot of time thinking about
and focusing on and optimizing for that
maybe that's a trade-off where they have
to spend less time hiring or less
there's a less competitive hiring market
I mean the instructors that we have now
there's no way on earth we could have
had
similar quality of instructor base in
San Francisco they're just there's
fundamentally is not hmm
so it's yes it's a trade off yeah it's
difficult it's a tricky one okay so the
last thing I want to cover is I've heard
you mention a couple interviews that the
market is not very good at measuring
product quality correct or something to
that effect right yeah so I think what I
usually say specifically analysts so
people who are and you know if you look
at public companies or VCS or whoever
else another way to say this I think PG
has said that product is or revenue is a
very very trailing indicator of product
right so I think and so I you know back
when I had spare time I would play the
stock market a lot okay and I think
people just don't have a very good
there's no way you can quantify product
quality very well so people who are
looking at things from a quantitative
standpoint underestimate it every single
time
mm-hmm I mean I look at some of the
classic companies like you know look at
the YC companies that Airbnb is the
stripe they all had competitors some of
their competitors had a head start some
of their competitors had more money and
more market share at different times but
there's a reason those companies win and
become durable companies another you
know Dropbox as an example well it's
it's one of my favorite Steve Jobs
videos I don't know if you've seen this
one before
but it's like a a very hot burn on
Microsoft and where he's just like
listen there are good people the problem
is they just have no taste
yeah and so I was curious about with you
is like do you think you can teach taste
in a school hmm - because it's very much
it's related to product it's related to
listening to users it's all of that but
there's something like more ethereal
about it you know I think that the main
thing is having thought about it a lot
and then having seen it and having
noticed it when you see it so but for
example we use slack as a school so
we've got I can tell you how much we
spend that would tell you how many
students we have it it's a non-trivial
amount of money for slack and people say
you know why don't you use you know
competitors or you know just use IRC but
like it's very very subtle the work that
has been put in the slack and slack has
it's not perfect right but as a product
you can just tell yeah and so it's a
whole lot of the way I like to think
about product is a whole lot of subtlety
built up over time to the point where it
becomes an advantage and if you build up
a lot of those advantages over time it
compounds to some degree and I think
because it's difficult to measure and
it's so subtle I mean if you for example
if you like drive a Model S and then you
go drive a similar cost Jaguar for
example the Model S like the materials
are worse the build is probably not as
good like they're not as good at like
assembling the pieces but just the
experience of that car versus the other
one it's not even close so Tesla is
probably the canonical example of like
product matters way more than analysts
can measure mmm-hmm cool so you just
think exposed students this over a long
enough time frame I think you show
people like the when I started to
realize it is when I had a few product
minded people like point out some of the
subtle details and be like you breathe
like you find yourself looking for one
app or one piece of software or using
something more often yeah and it takes
somebody to sit down and point out like
you know why you're doing that right
it's because this is happening at this
specific time in this specific way and
you're like oh that was very pleasant
actually
in retrospect and pointing that out and
then beginning to look for is when I
think you start to notice the the key
differences fair enough
yeah I like being critical sometimes
especially products
alright man so if people want to sign up
or learn more about lambda school where
should they go
yeah lambda school comm suite and you're
on Twitter at a tall stone covin e like
the feminist author not like the city
alright thanks for coming in probably
thank you
you